but the truth is university is a total
scam and it starts from the regulations
in the in Washington you title nine is
it is just one example of where they
have now sent down from hi you have to
comply with all of these new harassment
regulations and anti-racist and anti
massage need this stuff anti rape
culture whatever and if you don't we're
gonna take away your money and so then
what happens they have to go out and
they have to hire all these new people
all these new administrators all these
new programs all these offices if you
look at the chart of like tuition
expense it's gone up like this but like
the number of teachers is like this and
all this whole space is new university
administrators yeah so basically the
university is just is just funding all
these people that don't really do
anything or help your kids getting
education then the jacks up the price of
tuition and then they go out and they
give you get you this free money
basically and then put the handcuffs
around your wrists also that these
administrators can get fat and then all
the while they're donating money to the
universities and building up their
endowments so the university is using
the risks around the youth's to fund the
administrators to then fatten up their
endowment when really they should just
be using the money that people send them
for the endowment to lower the tuition
to make it possible for everyone else
it's snake oil to school it's snake oil
yeah it's and believe me I have these
conversations with my kids right my
eldest daughters 14
she's starting she's a very hyper
competitive you know high school they're
they're constantly saying if you don't
go to college you're gonna just live in
your mom's basement the rest of your
life etc etc you know she's taking AP
classes as a freshman he's gonna be
taking like always ape like busting her
butt right and my son same thing and
we're talking do you really need to go
to college and he's saying he's like dad
do I really need to go to college
anymore well you don't have to go to
college but you have to teach yourself
how to learn right you have to be some
skill you need a skill but the skill has
to be how to learn that's the first
skill you have to learn because you have
to be able to go out there and find the
information that you want now the thing
is is not everybody is gonna be able to
do that it takes a certain mindsets or
not bringing it certain access certain
privilege if it were as it were in order
to really learn how to teach yourself a
skill that's going to be marketable
you've done it I've
on it I learned a new thing I learned
everything about it then I put it into
practice it's just to who we are but
it's not everybody so I say this to my
kids hey you don't have to go to college
but it doesn't mean you don't have to do
anything like you have to learn you have
to learn how to learn on your own here's
the here's the problem I see with
college they tell you that in order to
get a good job you got to go to college
as if like it's a guarantee when you get
a diploma you could you're guaranteed a
job it's not possible and so what I what
I try telling people is all you need to
understand is that you need within
within a certain rule set rules set that
we have in law to convince mr. Jack is
sitting in front of me you're holding a
green picture of George Washington I
would like to hold that green picture
what do I have to say to you
to convince you to give it to me now
there's fraud laws you can't you can't
lie but there are reasonable things I
could do in fact one of them is can I
have that dollar right so what what
happens is people you know I thought
about this when I was a lot younger
dealing with my friends who are going to
college they're they're saying to me oh
I'm gonna get this great job and I said
what will they teach you in terms of
actually acquiring assets and money when
the court what the one core of what it
is to trade is that simple handing over
of the dollar or you know not swiping a
card or something they don't understand
the basic economic concepts of what
trade is what it represents what money
is and so they go to school thinking
that it's a snap of the fingers and now
you have a new car in an apartment so
I'll tell you a funny story I may have
told you guys if you watched my segments
I may have told us a while ago recently
I was hanging out at UIC in Chicago
which is you know University of Illinois
Chicago it's down it's like almost
downtown it was with a bunch of my
friends were a little younger than me
they were all talking about was my
friend and her friends and they were
talking about the things they were in a
school for their majors and how much
money they were gonna make one of them
looks to me and says what about you are
you in college because I was you know
two years older and I was like no I'm
not going to college and she was like
why do you want to like work at
McDonald's or something and I laughed
and I was like I'm not gonna work at
McDonald's no and I had words and fast
food anyway and she was like listen I'm
gonna graduate and I'm making $70,000 a
year
and you're gonna be at Starbucks and I
laughed and I was like you really think
you'll make 70
thousand dollars a year when you're 22
fresh out of college and she did yeah
something funny happened by the time she
had graduated I was a little bit older I
was a director at a non-profit I wasn't
making a ton of money but I had a
salaried career and I was direct I was a
director and as a fundraising branch
with no college and I'm a high school
dropout guess where she worked
Starbucks Starbucks because when she got
out she had no real world experience and
so who's going to hire that I mean look
you get a friend you get a buddy make
connection in college you can succeed
but I would say the only real benefit to
actually go into college is networking
you don't need to go to college to
network isn't networking and signaling
right yeah you get to tell the world
that you're part of this network and but
I I think that's a getting bit I think
it's getting bad actually it is and any
any industry that's really involved in
the making of things that actually
produces something if you can show them
that you know how to produce it they
don't right what college you went to no
it's actually the inverse now I think
college is becoming detrimental ya walk
because they also know you come out of
college with a certain mindset in a
certain ideology and debt and cash
requirements I got two stories for you
the the first is I knew this dude who
worked doing web dev in Chicago and he
got paid something like 30 30 grand a
year you know at the time it was like a
decent amount of money this is a long
time ago and he told me that he applied
for this job
he had self taught how to do web design
and the company said how much money do
you want and he had no college high
school dropout and he said I don't know
I was making like 12 bucks an hour
working fast food and they were like
how's 30 grand a year sound and he was
like what like that's so much better
and they straight up told him to his
face everyone who applied had a college
degree and they refused to accept what
we could afford because they had to pay
off their loans so we wanted to hire
them we don't have the money to do it we
literally only have this in the budget
your work looks great we've seen you
have the skills we don't care if you
have a diploma he could accept a lower
salary had a higher standard of living
right right yep right so I mean like
that but overall the college wage
premium is still a real thing
in an information market it does it does
it does add up but the information
economy also means that you have access
to all the information yourself so we're
out there and teach but really look if
there's anything that people should have
learned by this point is that dedication
to a corporation is suicide they don't
care about you and they never will know
there's no such thing as getting a job
in one place and staying there for your
whole life anymore that's not happening
it's a lottery ticket it's maybe but it
doesn't happen very often
and so really the whole thing is gonna
be about how are you going to build
yourself a set of skills that is good
you're gonna find a way to make money
with and it's not it's not about college
it's everybody everybody is gonna have
to be an entrepreneur just some degree
and this is why I think you know we've
seen the data that Gen Z is a little bit
more conservative than Millennials
there's a lot of reasons for this well I
have you have you heard this yet yeah
yeah one of the reasons I think goes
back to the 2000s when a report came out
saying liberals weren't having kids it's
a fact conservatives were at replacement
levels and liberals were at like 1.5 you
know per family or not yeah 1.5 so you
need at least two so now we're 1314
years later and yes there are more
conservative young people I also think
it's social media it's the
democratization and the breaking up of
you know it's become easier in some
sense and it's not in some sense to be
an entrepreneur I was at VidCon a couple
years ago there's big video convention I
walked past a group of little kids and
one kid goes I have 83 followers how
many followers do you have because you
have 83 I only have 60 and the other
kids like dude I have a hundred and
they're like what
over a hundred I laughed because it was
such a silly thing to see little kids
all excited about how many followers
they had but I started thinking these
kids are talking about the basics of
building a business yes they have
customers they have clientele yes so I
saw something there was like what's the
job what what job what's your dream job
asked of kids to be an influencer Yeah
right so my son my son he hustles all
the time he's selling candy at school he
buys at wholesale he brings it to school
he sells it for a profit but through
that adventure we have taught him what
financial statements are what a balance
sheet is what an income statement is
mark
getting price anchoring customer
management customer relations discounts
seasonal flows to business you know what
a return on investment is what a
profitable profit is what's the
difference between making an investment
or make an expense he's learned all this
through selling M&Ms and sour patch kids
at school for $2 that he buys for 50
Cent's yeah now you know every you have
he's not allowed to do that is he he's
not a lot he can he got but he did get
busted once yeah and they sent him home
and he waited like two weeks and with my
full support he went back at it cuz I
think I think it's awesome black market
candies go he saw $100 a week make him
50 no $50 a week he's 13 years old it's
crazy but the point is is I am taking
the time as a dad to sit down with him
and teach him what all this stuff means
we're building spreadsheets together
we're really looking at what a business
is and he's understanding it and now
there are you can see kids can see
they're on tik-tok every day
tick tock which I love by the way if you
got tick tock every day and you see
these people that just blow up into
businesses yep and so you know maybe the
kids are looking for lottery tickets in
that regard but at the same time even at
14 years old their little favorite tick
tock influencer got all this fame and
then it's starting to do product sales
and product placement and they and they
go and they live in these hype houses
and they build these little communities
they're witnessing firsthand
entrepreneurial activity that they can
relate to so I'm hoping that there's
gonna be you know sort of a new energy
of independent work and an
entrepreneurial business there but but
Jack you don't understand you just
describe to me your says header or
normative patriarchal privilege exactly
that son has a father teaching him these
things that's unfair I think the only
way for the society to be equal is to
take your child away from you so they
can grow up fatherless like all the
other kids that way they're equal right
you know you're you're being slightly
sarcastic you know me totally so totally
joking but it's scary when you look at
things like the APA the American
Psychological Association oh yeah last
year and basically pathologize masculine
behavior yep
so what's gonna happen in ten years if
these trends continue and you bring your
son to a doctor for stress and anxiety
but the doctors like well it's because
you're emphasizing competitive behavior
and risk-taking
you need to do you need to
dude him of that you need to strip him
away of his competition and his urge to
win you have to take that away from him
he can't be experiencing loss and losing
we're gonna medically castrate him but
you know why that will never happen it's
happening no no but you know well I know
I know but you know why it's not gonna
get to the point where we have a society
full of this there's two there's two
possibilities I don't know maybe there's
more than two Tommy complete collapse
because people go insane and are too
frail to actually function or more
importantly the ruthlessness of China
comes and shuts us down
well we if we if listen China's ruthless
yes they have they have now two
different kinds of camps for people who
are considered objectionable for one
reason other they have the Muslim Uighur
camps and now they have the coronavirus
camps they're doing oil exploration and
colonization in Africa and South America
they are ruthless they are invading the
South China Sea they're they're tearing
stuff up oh they're at war with us and
we are pretending that we're not
righteous why all the way back in 1999
battle for Seattle WTO stuff black bloc
was there and Tifa was there protesting
ironically processing WTO and China yep
we let China walk into our house steal
all of our stuff make us sick and then
they're gonna kill us and take us over
that's what the whole plan it's they're
at war with us and they have been for
you know a hundred years and so you know
we're not even talking about that and
that was one of the main reasons also
that I voted for Trump too because I
knew he's the only one talking about
anyone talking about yeah yep and it's
real I've been covering a lot of this
stuff or at least I've been in the
periphery of a lot of like really good
journalism where you know what China was
trying to build the Nicaraguan canal yes
compete with the Panama Canal it's like
it was one of the most environmentally
destructive projects ever proposed it
would have wiped out a major freshwater
basin in Central America didn't care
they did not care no they are they're
they're seizing land they're building
military bases they are pressing us in
the South China Sea
they are building on these atolls and
now we're hearing stories about
university professors who are secretly
receiving funding you buy that guy who
got charged like a federal charges Omar
Omar was a Harvard was it Harvard he was
those it was a time flight university
was the head of like the chemistry
department maybe we're being eaten we're
being you know burned up from the edge
Trump was the only one
to say China bad China bad yeah you know
Hillary Clinton said what China good you
know trying to go right EVP my reel of
China yeah Bernie Sanders said China bad
- he said TPP as well but now like his
he's singing a different tune it's it's
it's it's like a complete 180 yeah so
you know right now you got everyone's
screaming Russia meanwhile I think
Russia is not as big a deal as they make
it out to be they're they're
exaggerating Russian BOTS
they probably accuse you of being a
Russian 50 million times excuse me of
doing it and it's actually China yeah
that's that's engaging in a bunch of
cyber attacks in literal military
campaigns they're putting people in
concentration camps and I get this virus
outbreak they've been lying about it
it's gonna get bad and I think
regardless of whether or not the
conspiracy theory is true some people
believe that you know China has been
funding these universities and they're
these professors to spread these ideas
that would weaken America its core yeah
I don't know if you've probably heard
that or it makes perfect sense I don't I
don't care for the conspiracies right so
the general ideas have been a bunch of
professors who have been outed for
secretly receiving funding from China I
don't care it doesn't matter what's
causing it matters that it's true that
if we end up with a bunch of snow plow
babies you know these kids whose parents
have made sure there's no obstacles in
front of them they're frail weak and
scared emasculated who's going to defend
us when you know when the u-boats come
across our shores me and the men in the
liminal order an order calm come join us
guys come join us how many how many
people do you have we've had over 170
people join us we've got meetings in New
York LA San Fran Denver Austin Nashville
DC we're expanding where we've even got
people all over the world growth is
coming growth is happening we're
spreading there's meetings everywhere
it's really a fantastic place if any of
these issues we've talked about today if
any of the stuff that we've talked about
today means anything to you and you feel
like you're alone and where you are at
home or you're the only guy at your
office that thinks this way and you
can't talk to anybody about this stuff
come join us man we are probably the
nerdiest group of guys out there because
we're thinking about all the stuff
intellectually this is not a get paid
get laid kind of thing this is a
thinking man's organization and we have
personal development and an academy
where we're teaching people personal
sovereignty how to be more discerning
how to make better choices how to embody
your ideals how to have more integrity
we're teaching people about the way that
China is engaging with us in military
strategy fourth-generation warfare we're
teaching people how to think how to
think logically how to identify truth
and we're doing it together in a
community of men to support each other
you guys do you familiar with the N AP n
AP the non-aggression principle no it's
like a it's a libertarian tennant
basically you don't aggress or offend
against somebody else in terms of like
causing real physical harm or violence
or anything like better that's us I mean
look how curious if you oh no I'm not
familiar with that but we're I think we
would say that we're all sort of like
evolved libertarians you know we realize
that the libertarian should be left in
sort of the classroom not in reality but
with that sort of that's sort of the way
that we believe you know the sort of a
fundamental notion we believe in
independent independence individualism
taking care of yourself your family your
community and then maybe the nation and
it's done we have forums we have chats
we have in group meetings we have
chapters all over the country and it's
about making ourselves a better people
so that we can be better for our
community and this is our response okay
this is what we're doing I'm not just
out here complaining about the left and
their ideas and all these terrible
things we're actually doing stuff and
this is stuff on the ground with real
people real relationships real community
real impact real lifting of each other
up we've been there we've had guys go
through deaths miscarriages job loss
people have rallied together we donate
money we support them you know it's a
it's it's something that's missing
there's a real sense of community ran
where you care about each other they're
coming for you bro
they are come they're gonna call you
every name in the book well you know the
New York Times has already been asking
questions Politico Daily Beast's you
know and I say to all of them go away
they're gonna make stuff up hey you're
gonna keep I've already I've already
been called a Nazi a bigot is a
misogynistic rape advocate I think I
will be able to whether that's a right
on yeah all right well I think I think
we've sort of beat the horse of death we
did we did we did great thank you very
much for happen oh no did I I'm glad you
came out do you want to mention your you
yeah I'm gonna hit it Jack Murphy live
at Jack Murphy live on Twitter Facebook
YouTube Instagram everywhere the book is
Democrat to deplorable why 9 million
Obama voters ditch the Democrats and
embrace Donald Trump you can find that
on Amazon we're running a sale on the
Kindle right now almost all five-star
ratings for that and then of course the
liminal order which is where you can
find me every day liminal - order calm
membership is closed right now but sign
up for the waiting list because it is
going to be reopening very soon so come
on down and check it out comen yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you